okay I'm Nigel Morrison on the CEO of
isobar which is a digital marketing
network and I actually don't think that
the environment is going to lose out to
the economy in 2009 partly the reason
for that is that term the economy is in
many respects subset of the environment
I think people are beginning to realize
that the old models of mass the old
models of producing things that we don't
need of consuming things that we don't
really need to consume in the West is
actually broken and actually people are
beginning to realize the sustainable
motor consumptions sustainable mode of
production are the only things that are
going to generate sustainable jobs
because it's a great sustainable
economies and actually going to get us
back to having a real economy in a real
world and that's interesting coming from
may be coming from someone who works in
digital actually again I think that
digital is going to be the key driver
that's because one the more and more of
the business processes the migrate
towards digital a less impact they're
going to have in the physical world so
anything that can be done digitally will
it can start to become done digitally
and the other thing is going to be
enormous pressure on business on
politicians to act sustainably more
responsibly ethically because everything
we do is now transparent this really is
all about everyone being connected to
everyone else in anything they're
interested in what we have is a world in
which there is a transparency of action
that you're two clicks away from finding
out whether someone has actually done
what they said they were going to do and
so therefore I think if you look at the
macro pressure of the last 20 years has
been about the environment that the
economy is it's it's a it's a blip but
it's a very very big blend but actually
it's going to be a tipping point that
takes sustainability takes the
environment really really seriously it's
actually a critical year
for that thank you